i mean nobody puts it together like the
only person i heard that puts it
together like rbx is the originator of
style to me and that's dlc shout out to
the dlc doc
doc was all style he's just the way he
worded it and put it together with the
whopping one of the biggest like what it
is if he had never got in that accident
you know and his sheesh man
right the big i think that's one of the
biggest what-ifs of hip-hop history oh
yeah you know because man you know what
i'm saying like wow he was sewing a role
at that time
you know what i'm saying he was about to
be
you know where snoop
was and became right dlc was on his way
to be that guy first no and it's crazy
because see that happened to doc
which stopped him from going to that
place
and we see snoopy at right now
uh
iconic
yes and then the same thing happened
with nipsy hustle yeah
and nipsey was on his way to being on
that level he was man like snoopy
they were just favorites you know dog
was a favorite he came out they loved
him from the door deep cover
gum
you know what i'm saying
which sparked everything from that point
they already had the chronic in mind but
deep coverage just flew him to the top
right right right you know what i'm
saying already before the chronic even
came out so
you know same thing with with dlc
and with nip
you know what i mean and there's others
out there that had that up that
potential
to be something special and different